sapete ragazzi quand'è che si capisce
che proprio una giornata di merda quando
ti svegli la mattina si scopre di avere
un fratello
porca [ __ ] per tutti ragazzi è
pervenuto questo video sono va vj ed
affissioni tornati su sixty seconds e da
una vita e mezza che non faccio sixty
seconds veramente e facciano altri
episodi ragazzi perché l'hanno
aggiornato non so che cosa hanno fatto
non ne ho idea non ho capito che cosa
hanno aggiunto però hanno fatto
aggiornamenti quindi vediamo che cosa
così a bello adesso cadono le cose c'è
una nucleare che sta arrivando togliti
immobile del cazzo madonna già andato
accesso e scusate devo muovere il culo
non mi ricordo neanche ragazzi cui si
prendono leggo anzi proprio zero
vai vai vai mio figlio mio figlio devo
dare dei nipoti a questo mondo mia
figlia che vale tre non la posso
prendere perché obesa la cosa che mi ha
sempre fatto più ridere che vorrei che
sti stronzi raccolgono qualcosa cioè per
l'amor di dio sa che i ragazzi ce l'ho
fatta non so come ci ho messo una vita e
mezza tra l'altro prove non so anche che
cazzo pur eto'o prove chi se ne frega
l'importante ragazzi avere gli in voi va
che non è che non posso andare avanti in
pokémon mentre c'era nucleare ma ce
l'avete la fibra lì sotto ad ai ragazzi
un che ho preso la mappa il che potrebbe
essere un vantaggio e poi la rai e l'ho
presa la rabbia o presenta stico primo
giorno ragazzi oddio contatto è passato
dall'ultima volta che ho fatto
abbiamo le carte ragazzi abbiamo le
carte cosa fantastica abbiamo un sacco
di zuppa di scatole di zuppa il culo mi
ricordo neanche come si gioca a vedere
il mio amico ogni quanto devo dargli da
mangiare asti cristiani partiamo subito
dalla ricognizione ragazzi mandiamo il
padre ricognizione immediatamente
possono andare solo uno abbia solo
avesse raggiunto la possibilità di
mandarne di più visto che già uno crepa
ma perché perdiamo due ragazzi
l'importante che muoia qualcuno così non
devo dare
risorse a tutti quanti possiamo far
schiattare la figlia che in di mary jane
continua chi è mary jane la moglie o la
moglie dolores mary jane e alla figlia
kimi al figlio mary jane ha bisogno
d'acqua timi ha bisogno d'acqua dolores
ha bisogno d'acqua ed sarà andata a
[ __ ] quindi non beh vediamo
dell'acqua tutti quanti oggi giusto
perché ciò voglia di far festa è perché
sennò cazzo
stiamo facendo del nostro meglio per
rimanere calmi la situazione dove siamo
e fuori dal normale ma tie in attesa che
non puoi anche andare su youporn
speriamo che gli aiuti arriveranno in
fretta la rai la radio si sente solo
radio maria
per adesso ce l'avete mai al culetto ci
siamo svegliati stamattina come se
qualcuno qualcosa ci stesse guardando
abbiamo notato un movimento nell'ombra
c'è qualcosa vivo dentro bunker c'è un
mucchio di un metro come cazzo fai non
accorgerti ma siete scemi
basta che non mi sparate a vicenda
perché non è normale non certo successo
qualsiasi cosa fosse morto ma cos'era
qualsiasi cosa fosse morto ora
abbastanza morto sarebbe una buona idea
scoprire che cosa sta succedendo là
fuori magari abbiamo sentito l'annuncio
del governo del fallout upside quindi il
fallout sarebbe fallout quindi l'era di
lem tutti i videogiochi di fallout fuori
se ne sono andati dovrebbe essere molto
più sicuro camminare in superficie ora
dov'è il papa reale me già morto l'ho
mandato all'inizio era pieno di forze
fastidio quando non dico natura o per
l'amor di dio grazie è servita vacanza e
terme vero zia tutto tu c'hai starvation
sick and tired gli altri sono sono
stanchi questi due annunciano un cazzo
ecco i due giocano le game boy same date
un game boy e mi mettete in un bunker ci
vivo tutta la vita buona notizia il
governo ha fatto un radio broadcast
per quanto riguarda l'estrazione dei
sopravvissuti che nella nostra area
aveva perfetto ed è tornato dal suo
viaggio nella superficie mi chiamo
vorranno resort
oddio grandi madonna quanto la d'oro
quanto andato in un bar e ha trovato
della colla e meno male allora iniziamo
ted è stanco è ammalato ci ha fame ai
compiti da fare non mangia qualcosa oggi
potrebbe finire male
hai detto di darti da bere io non ti do
da bere cazzi tuoi solo da magna mary
jane è più che pronta per andare fuori
va bene e adesso la prendo la mando ti
giuro che ti ammazzo se muore no ma
serio gli preferirebbe del succo di mela
una tutela c'erano poi anche il
cameriere ziona dimmelo magari un
parrucchiere con quella merda che c'è in
testa a mary jane
buona fortuna per il tuo viaggio in
superficie se non torni lo sai cosa ti
aspetta esco col fucile e ti vengo a
cercare non ti sparo e quel fucile
totale in filo e basta a lei manca la
chicca si vede che proprio è in
astinenza da trucchi non ho capito cosa
vogliono fare ragazzi prova governo
metto lacrime nel dubbio poi ognuno la
satira un intenso quanto vi ammazzerei
1x1 finché non chiedete p et al
al diavolo mamma mia che fasti bene non
abbiamo rotta grandi solo quello poteva
salvarvi teste di mary mead adesso per
punizione non vi do un cazzo mary jane
tesoro che tom andata fuori che di più
che pronta per tornare dove cazzo sei
mostre a voler fare uno scambio uno
straniero che cosa nuova
una bottiglia d'acqua in cambio delle
carte da una bottiglia d'acqua in cambio
del dello spray due bottiglie d'acqua in
cambio del
del manuale di sopravvivenza e una in
cambio della torcia gli direi di
scambiare il boy scout grasso nei server
boy scout il turno dopo mi serviva
quello scommettete brava mary jane brava
e trovate una flashlight c'è questa qui
è andata fuori una [ __ ] settimana è
l'unica cosa che ho trovato è una cazzo
di torcia 6 seria e doveva andare fuori
a finali il fucile non ce lo aspettavamo
di ricevere una chiamata ma chiamata a
tavano il telefono ma siete scemi allora
non avete chiamato voi possiamo sentire
un telefono a un telefono che squilla
fuori a ok vorrebbe qualcuno andare a
rispondere minchia bikemi fatti coraggio
mai era la nonna che chiamava e chiedeva
se hanno mangiato perché la nonna si
preoccupa sempre di mangiare nonno è
stata la bomba atomica e sopra tutti nel
bunker ci sparano per hai mangiato
erano di sopravvissuti della città
vicino della il valle abbiamo iniziato a
scambiarci informazioni quando la
chiamata s'è interrotta qualcosa deve
essere andato storto dalla loro parte mi
chiamano male che non era dalla nostra
sono perdevamo il bambino che dai
andiamo del cibo a tutti che la sete
merita tanto ci abbiamo tanta di quella
zuppa che possiamo aprire l'esselunga sì
mi sembra entusiasta di andare fuori di
rai.tv sei tutti noi rai team bike in mi
min causa i fantagenitori per salvarti
abbia trovato una valigetta alla porta
dovremo controllare dai perché dovete
dargli queste responsabilità che poi
esplode tutto no non lo fare non lo fa
io sono convintissimo che sia una bomba
a una roba del genere ma convinto
proprio dei renis sono ovunque non
sembrano spaventati da noi toschi fo
dobbiamo cambiare le cose non vogliamo
altri ragni nella nostra zuppa no
signore dio la zuppa di ragnick a ma
siamo seri e che si mangia la zuppa di
ragni ma spruzza sforzellina famiglia e
socialmente grossi che celano
l'apriscatole incorporato proprio nelle
zampe fantastico l'altro giorno abbiamo
sentito bussare uno strappo ancora
abbiamo trovato una suite cage uguale a
prima
non li voglio ai vostri regali di merda
sono in promozione quelli dell'ikea e ti
mandano i mobili a caso ma è mia
intenzione di tornare prima o poi si
grazie a dio
oddio frequente molto il padre per quale
motivo a eventi si era ammalato ho
capito non c'avevo i medikit cosa volevi
che facesse mai che mi di mira è trovato
qualcosa timida mi delle news di mika è
trovato qualcosa croft lo zoom madonna
abbiamo trovato una valigetta piena di
banconote che cosa mi servono le
banconote noi abbiamo trovato anche un
lucchetto vabbè se fai un lucchetto eva
tutte e due
tutte lui ce l'ha in bici ha fame non si
sente bene e affaticato e che è
impazzito e stanco tutto lui della
qualcuno ci ha fatto una visita oggi e
ci da una radio oddio per la valigetta
tiene intenti età regalo tutta regalo
proprio tutta tua
vedrai da messa radio affanculo ragazzi
accendete st radio per l'amor di dio che
non è possibile sopravvivere ancora
un'altra chiamata dai militari si è
maledizione hanno bisogno di localizzare
in creare azioni in chiara siamo hanno
detto che per riconoscere dove siamo
localizzati dobbiamo lasciare dei marchi
in giro hanno detto che i marchi
dovrebbero essere delle carte dobbiamo
andare fuori il più vicino possibile
alla fermata dell'autobus e mettere
delle carte mettiamo le carte che se
devo dire sì vabbè ma chi è che ci mandi
ci hai mandato fuori lo hanno lanciato
le carte da non si sa dove però l'hanno
messe l'aveva importante quello questa
ed efficiente mary jane ha deciso di
ingoiare le batterie della torcia solo
quella hai portato brutta minchiona la
sicura magnata i miei guarito dalla
pazzia anche mary jane sono vari
istituti dalla pazzia non ci credo di
mick e mary jane torna con delle
bottiglie perché sono perso mary jane ti
prego dove tim.it mi stava molto male
non c'è stato niente da fare è morto a
se ne andranno se n'è andato però
minchia dolore si dovrebbe mangiare
qualcosa in maniera tanto da magna ne
abbiamo e l'acqua che è finita ragazzi
40 giorni
40 gol che aveva fatto sopravvivere cosa
fa perché sta così mary jane sarebbe
dovuta tornare da giorni è passato
troppo tempo dai perché palle dai
rimasta viva solo la madre morta anche
mary j
no sono [ __ ] davanti c'era la radio
l'annuncio radio sono un [ __ ] sono
andata avanti a caso ragazzi abbiamo
perso per forza perché i soldati non
arrivano modonna 46 giorni sono passati
dolore se non sopravviverà senza sensato
ancora a lungo
cosa vuoi dalla mia vita non posso farci
niente la mappa non so che quando l'ho
letto non me ne frega un cazzo dargliela
no dai nicchia 46 giorni 46 fottuti
george 47 sono sopravvissuto per 47
giorni non so come casinò fatto da avevo
lasciato le carte sulla fermata
dell'autobus quando a natale è servita a
niente niente ragazzi ci ho riprovato
dopo anni speravo che arrivassero
sticazzi militari ma non arrivano prima
o poi lo finisco ve lo prometto perché
non è possibile che dopo cinque episodi
ancora niente ma dovete morire tutti
però non dopo che due ragazzi spero
è piaciuto 47 giorni meritano un like
almeno quelli che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi come primo che l'episodio cava
santos e video risulta sull'argomento è
un mi piace anche la pagina di facebook
e come vino prescrizione sono se non
siete iscritti ci vediamo al prossimo
video dei ragazzi
[Musica]